do you think you guys think it's
appropriate to go out in a relationship
yeah why not is it is that a bad thing
though I think no dust yourself when
you're out well what are you going out
for whoa
what let my hair down for five minutes
oh my God it's like why are you fishing
if you don't want to fish
so would you go out for yourself to have
a good time is that no seriously is that
a thing now I mean that's just I'm just
telling you guys how men view it like
I'm just being honest like I listen to
guys talk all the time like if you're
going out all the time it's like
you can you can say like I I'm I'm not a
hoe right but if all your friends are
hoes you're going out to the club all
the time it's like you're dressing like
a hoe acting like a hoe it's like how
are they supposed to think you're not a
hoe